-Performing "Eucalyptus,"
from their new album, "First Two
Pages of Frankenstein,"
please welcome The National!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ What about
the glass dandelions? ♪
♪ What about the TV screen? ♪
♪ What about
the undeveloped camera? ♪
♪ Maybe we should bury these ♪
-♪ What about
the last of the good ones? ♪
♪ What about the ceiling fans? ♪
♪ What if we moved back
to New York? ♪
♪ What about
the moon drop light? ♪
♪ You should take it ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm not gonna take it ♪
♪ I'm only gonna break it ♪
♪ You should take it ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm not gonna take it ♪
♪ You should take it,
you should take it ♪
♪ What about
the rainbow eucalyptus? ♪
♪ What about the instruments? ♪
♪ What about
the Cowboy Junkies? ♪
♪ What about the Afghan Whigs? ♪
♪ What about
the Mountain Valley Spring? ♪
♪ What about the ornaments? ♪
♪ What if I reinvented again? ♪
♪ What about
the moon drop light? ♪
♪ You should take it ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm not gonna take it ♪
♪ You should it take it ♪
♪ I'm only gonna break it ♪
♪ You should take it ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm not gonna take it ♪
♪ You should take it,
you should take it ♪
♪ You should take it ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm not gonna take it ♪
♪ If I miss it, I'll visit ♪
♪ You should take it ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm not gonna take it ♪
♪ You should take it,
you should take it ♪
♪♪
♪ I don't want it,
I don't care ♪
it wouldn't be fair ♪
♪ Woah-oh ♪
♪ It'd be so alone
without you there ♪
♪ Ahh, it wouldn't be fair,
it wouldn't be fair ♪
♪ Ahh ♪
♪ There's nobody home,
I'm already there ♪
♪ Ahh, it wouldn't be fair ♪
♪ You should take it ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm not gonna take it ♪
♪ I'm only gonna break it ♪
♪ You should take it ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm not gonna take it ♪
♪ You should take it,
you should take it ♪
♪ You should take it ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm not gonna take it ♪
♪ If I miss it, I'll visit ♪
♪ You should take it ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm not gonna take it ♪
♪ It wouldn't be fair ♪
♪ Ahh-ahh ♪
♪ It'd be so alone
without you there ♪
♪ It wouldn't be fair,
it wouldn't be fair ♪
♪ Ahh ♪
♪ There's nobody home,
I'm already there ♪
♪ Ahh, it wouldn't be fair ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]